so at 13 years old I had a UH out of
kill list
I got a hunt them down
now you got a problems right I don't
think I've ever said this before
seriously seriously this is gonna be fun
Michael and particularly become my big
brother the greatest of all time but we
call them black Jesus you're not
intimidating me we're gonna go at it
that's crazy yeah man you're about to
take your shot and on all of a sudden
boom the kiss of death you know my back
was really spasming how the hell do you
tolerate that kind of pain I play games
with the flu I play games with 102
degree fever man power they all thought
I was absolutely crazy the day me a shag
on the fist fight that's fine
oh yeah that's why I'm not backing down
listen you gotta throw me to Boston man
that get it off the rebound if I
miss bro you told them this it doesn't
bother you I'm finding what the hell do
you want me to do got it
[Music]
you